okay
hello to everybody joining this live
stream
uh our topic today is a fairly
detailed wolfram language design issue
um and this is what it's about context
aliases
so let's take a look hopefully there are
some examples here
yes somebody introduced what the basic
idea is here
right okay so this is this is a design
that i mocked up and i've run past a
number of people
uh i think all of whom are in this
meeting uh
and the idea is is to try to do
something
like you see in some other languages
like javascript for example where you
can
uh have you know some long
decorative context uh but be able to
uh you know in a particular piece of
code to alias that
context uh so it's an alternative to
dollar context path you know dollar
context path has the problem that
it can lead to name collisions quite
easily
um and so the idea is rather than having
a name
collision uh that you're still using
context but you're using easier to type
context
okay so another way to think about this
is you could have a
variable called you know uh
flipperwoggle global something or other
and you can say
f equals that that's not at the context
level that's at the symbol name level
yeah right so in a sense what you're
saying
is you would like to have a
name for a context just like a symbol is
a name for an expression
yes yes that's very much it
okay
and so given that general goal this
is my specific proposal to uh
you know to achieve that goal uh it
affects
several things but uh i you know i put
the
all the documentation in this one you
know
for for purposes of reviewing the
proposal i put all the documentation
just in this one notebook
for now and so so basically you know in
a first approximation
in some different world of syntax
we could imagine something where you say
cc
colon colon equals you know
blah blah blah blah
and of course you may not want yeah i
mean yeah that's the point is that
you want to be able to access the blah
blah blah blah blah
but you don't necessarily want all of
its symbols coming
into your dollar context path yeah i get
it
yeah so i mean
and there are some downstream changes
that follow from that
and and one of the big uh uh you know
things that we're thinking about is in
terms of the paklet repository
is that uh you know the paclet
repository
will will be difficult to use if we have
to
guarantee that every name exposed by
every paclet you know
can't conflict with any other name and
any other i mean that's the story of the
function repository that we have to
uniquify all those names yeah uh and of
course
it gets much worse with a packet that
might ex legitimately expose
dozens or hundreds of functions yes well
i agree with you i mean i think that
that's a
okay so let's just understand the
different strategies okay
so okay
let's look at our hierarchy system
context
we're very tightly controlling those
names we are
sorry that we used a few names like set
for example many many years ago
that probably should have been a more
decorated name okay
but that's the way it is and it so let's
write down our sort of hierarchy of
naming
okay
so one is system context
system names
okay so one feature is they are
carefully controlled they can never
change
right um
oh my god there's another feature of a
system
of system context names you can never
escape from them they are
always present
that's not true i mean it would be a
really bad idea but you could certainly
change dollar context path to to
remove system yeah you try that
the front end won't like it for a scar
right i'm not saying it's a good idea
i'm just saying you can't escape
what section should i put this in
yeah it's it's fundamental to the paclet
repository so
maybe there it's also it's also
potentially related to package
the package stuff that we've been doing
okay all right then we've got
okay um
you know wolfram repository names
we've also got private repository names
i'm just trying to understand this for a
second
um
then we've got sort of context names
but even there there's a same issue
right i mean there's
you know two people could in principle
have the same
there's context names but there's okay
there's also potentially user uniquified
contact in this names if
we're going right and so in the context
of the paclet repository
uh what we've been proposing is that
uh we enforce a
uh a rule that basically you know so you
have a
publishing name you know it you know as
part of your user account you have a
publisher name
uh and does it contain characters that
couldn't be in a context name
uh that's i think a tangent not
okay but if it does we'll give you a
slug that doesn't
yeah yeah so uh and then
uh of the things that you've published
of course
you know you you will have uh a name for
your packlet
and you know you aren't going to have
two pack lists of the same name
someone else might have a paclet with
the same name you've chosen under a
different publisher name
and so then what we've proposed is that
we're going to
enforce and this would be you know
through scanning and such
enforce no symbol creation
outside of uh you know if you want to
submit and be accepted to the pack
repository no symbol creation
outside of uh you know the context which
is
your publisher name backtick your
uh paclet name
okay and so that's a that then becomes a
guaranteed unique
uh uh context so long as you're in
the public paclit repository right
right exactly um however of course
people will want descriptive publisher
names and descriptive paclet names
that's
entirely understandable and then that
will lead to a lot of typing
um yeah so
that's that's a lot of what drives the
the kind of urgency
i think behind an aliasing proposal
okay so there's a question in the
repositories
would it make any sense with this
happening
here
to actually provide maybe this is crazy
um
to actually provide the the functions in
a context like that
so you can access them not through the
the resource function blob is that is
that crazy
it's not clear to me that it is crazy i
mean
first of all you already can right
because they have to have some symbol
attached to them
i know but they have uuid symbol names
don't they guys
yes yeah and you're suggesting you'd
want that
to load the resource to figure out what
symbol to get right probably yeah i i
think the principal craziness here
is you know uh is
potential craziness is at what point
does the definition get attached to the
descriptive symbol name
right well can't it be an auto load
i don't know someone else would have to
answer that
uh i mean i mean how would it know that
that is
i mean right but how about if we have a
notion of an auto load on a context not
a loadable context
where anything in that context that you
ask for
is something for which you try and look
up an auto load
um
we certainly have no mechanism for that
i mean i know we don't have a mechanism
right now but i'm just saying
as a possible thing and then the same
thing could be done here with the paclet
you know if you say um
you know the um
you know
something like this well auto loading of
the
packlet is a potentially more complex
story
um because there might be it isn't just
a package
as well as it could right right i mean
even if it is just a package there might
be some dynamic set of
symbols i don't know how common that is
but but yes it might very well have
dependencies
other than simple but but if i might
i mean you know just as a paclet hooks
itself into
all kinds of things like the palettes
list and so on and so on and so on
one of the things the paclic could hook
itself into is an autoloading mechanism
john you don't have anything about the
packlet symbol proposal in here do you
no okay we have a proposal that was
probably for another meeting
to have a new symbol called packlet
symbol that would
wrap a paclet name and a symbol name and
do the auto loading
and in in the case of the repository you
would install as well
download and well that's not installed
download and load
uh context as needed yeah i'd actually
and then it would have gotten that
proposal so thanks
and then it would turn into the sim the
fully qualified symbol
in place sort of thing as an evaluation
time thing
exactly right
okay i'm not completely getting that but
yeah okay fair enough
it would serve the same purpose as the
autoloading but it would have some
limitations because
it's a wrapping symbol so holding
attributes and
own values and stuff would be a little
different
all right let's go back stephen stephen
do you want this alan turing machines
halting queue do you want that to work
to load a
code from a packet that isn't yet
installed
well i was imagined for packaging but i
understand that that might not make any
sense
i mean i was imagining that were i to
have that in a piece of code
then just like the fact that you know
just like the really nice thing i mean
you know okay so listen you know i use
the function repository stuff
every day it's really useful to be able
to have this thing where i'm not
grunging around trying to figure out
where is it and do i have it installed
on a new machine
and i send the code to somebody else and
they don't have it installed and all the
usual nonsense
right the mechanism we have right now is
really nice
and you know possibly this is a
generalization of that mechanism
that would work for any paclet but i
mean
essentially uh the same idea
as a you know function repository
function thing for packlets
it's kind of the same way it would load
the packet
i think it's a good idea you know i i
think that the case where it works well
is when you know when it's a function
name
basically and where you know when i say
resource function
of
why why why do i have that stupid extra
thing in the autocomplete
john uh it's it's uh whack-a-mole
we we we will okay there's another
one i'll send a message off yeah another
mole
put it back in the ground or whatever
whack it i believe it's an expression
but it's moles on the ground right it's
not moles of of avogadro's number or
anything like that
yeah uh sydney archangel be interested
to know how to whack avogadro's
well it takes a really long time because
there are six point three two two thumbs
down yeah
one third of them um okay
uh okay so let's say something like this
why was i doing this i mean to me this
is a nice
clean thing i mean i i would literally
love
us to have some kind of um you know more
control equalsy way to enter that
but that brings me to the possibility
that
you know okay so we've got this fine
and now here if i evaluate that i get
that
which i still i think maybe the design
of this could be cleaned up a bit
but the question really is i think this
is a little bit too heavy weight i think
we should take down the
the the heaviness of that border by the
way
i know that's irrelevant to this meeting
but maybe somebody can
can take that point in can somebody do
that
yeah stephen i did that okay
um but but what you're suggesting is
the same kind of thing a blob basically
that is generated by a piece of code
the idea is that it would evaluate to
this symbol so if if you evaluate it
you'll get out
something that has full context it won't
stay a blob after evaluation is the idea
for this okay it's a little different
fine but but then this but you see but
this somehow relates to your aliasing
thing because
what you're saying is well no i i
disagree with that statement right the
aliasing
is is right i don't want to have to
write paclet symbol
blah blah blah if i'm writing a bunch of
right if i'm writing my note package
which uses a paclet right i don't want
to do that i want to load the packet
once
and then have an easy way to access all
i know
i get it i get it i get it i i think
there are two
two approaches to accomplish something
similar i i
we've talked about this before todd and
some other people that packlet symbol is
we think of as like the trial period for
a paclet
yeah if you're writing if you're writing
production code right you know
code that needs to be fast and and
you know not have any weird state around
it you're not going to use pacle symbol
exactly paclet symbol is the interactive
notebook case it's not yes
exactly it's the case similar to the
function repository case
it's the case where there's a great big
packet out there and i just want one
little function that i'm going to use
from it
correct in a and in a you know
prototyping
development playing around sort of way
often right and you don't want to have
to type
backward install blah and then needs
blah
right it's it encapsulates all of that
right but so the point that i'm making
about the aliasing is this
okay the what you're saying is
this would evaluate to this right
right okay so what i'm saying is if
there is also an alias here
then this could i mean i don't know
whether whether it makes sense but
um it's not quite evaluation
there's something that happens at scan
time
i understand that causes this to expand
to this but i'm saying that in terms of
print form
so you know one question is assume
you've done the aliasing and then you
enter this long name
does it print with the alias or not no
no no the alias is purely
uh you know a tokenizing scanning
tokenizing thing
it's not for output the way i've written
it up
okay all right okay fine okay
so you have more than one alias to the
same thing
of course yes right so that
right that sort of answers the question
of whether it can use the alias for
output
exactly fine okay
right okay dead dead story okay
so then um
[Music]
right okay so
here you're guaranteeing that these
paclitified names are unique
aliases and for example paclit might use
aliases which might step on other
aliases defined by another
well the point is that the paclet
doesn't declare the alias
you declared the alias okay so the
packet never
i mean i know that you know this usually
so so this is part of the proposal
is that you can use the alias internal
to your package
and it will not the alias you chose will
not escape your package
so you can conveniently author your code
however you want and as long as it's
bundled up in a
begin and begin package and package then
it's contained
i see but how does it do that i mean
isn't it an evaluation time thing
to set up the aliens so so i mean we
haven't actually looked at the proposal
yet
at some point we have to look at the
actual proposal okay all right fine fine
and if you could increase the
magnification a bit
okay okay so you know the the idea of
the proposal was kind of
you know starting with something like
dollar context path
uh uh and you know i use that as an
inspiration
for how to how to construct this so
dollar context aliases it's an
association and it's
you know it's basically just uh rules of
uh alias context um
you can modify dollar context aliases
directly
but it can also be modified by things
like needs begin package and package
uh beginning so i forget what needs okay
so needs normally
has a context and a file so what what
you're proposing i would suspect
is something it's actually in the in the
exclu
excluded marked paragraph there is is
what i'm proposing
you know what we were about to propose
the same thing
we'll fancy that yeah i was going to
propose that
yeah uh and
the one of the important things to
understand about this is that it
uh you can use this syntax to specify an
alias or not you might specify none in
which case there wouldn't be an alias
but either way
this syntax changes the behavior of
needs so that needs
no longer adds the context of dollar
context path
i get it right but it well i mean
wouldn't it be more accurate to say that
needs does not allow
context path to be modified right
because isn't it actually begin package
and
end package that add it to the context
path
ah it is it's unpackaged it adds it to
the contract's path
okay no i i i prefer to talk about that
okay so
in the modernized concept of how
packages will work
which hopefully connor will get to work
on soon
how would this work
the approach taken with the you know the
modern package format is
is pretty different because it it
defines a whole different
sort of phased you know approach to
loading packages
um so there's there's an analogous
concept of of you know aliasing symbols
or contexts but
it's very different than what's
happening here where things are being
loaded dynamically
explain more so but the question is well
this design will just get blown up by
that
well i think i mean i think obviously
we'd really want them to be
to function quite similarly so that you
know there isn't as you said
a blow up because they do fairly
different things
but that's still an open question how to
integrate this design into the design of
the the new package format
but the new package format is a scan
time story mostly is that correct rather
than an evaluation time story
rather than a begin package which
happens at evaluation time
there is a mechanism which i remember
talking about like two years ago but i
can't remember there's a syntax for it
right there was some
uh yeah there's there's a small i mean
this details of syntax are not nailed
down but the idea is there's a
special syntax for making those metal
level you know directives for how the
package should be parsed
yes um so you have you know things like
package import package export package uh
package symbol um there there's a couple
others but
that's right but those are those are
indicated in some special way
in the source code that is picked up by
the scanner is that correct
correct
i think what we looked at was some kind
of like prefixed at sign
um a long long time ago but i don't
think we ever
so it's pseudo or language syntax
with yeah yeah okay
okay so let me just understand that for
a second so that would be that would set
up the whole package
scope thing
and the basic bottom line for a package
is
a package defines a context and
puts its symbols in those content in the
context
and then it either does or doesn't
add that context to the context path is
that correct
that's that's the i mean package export
would add that context to the context
path is that true or is that not true
i mean that's what end package does
right now is add the context to the
context path
am i right and package is what
adds the context to the context path i
mean package
export the the existing package export
is something slightly different that
says
place this symbol in the actual context
of the package rather than in an
internal
hidden away context so it's a way of
sort of distinguishing between
okay is there an existing package export
no
uh i think there is isn't that what it's
called there's
uh no there's a thing
there's begin and begin package
uh and uh i mean what is all this crud
here look at this
look at that crud
there is no package export i'm sure
there isn't i'm sure there are very few
there's begin package and package which
are unfortunately going to be kind of
you know they're going to have the
family name but not be part of the
package
function family i suspect but isn't
package export part of the
current new package format isn't that a
symbol that you can put into a package
file
what does the new package find the new
package format is not yet implemented
anywhere right
well there is there is something i mean
there is something called a new package
format which is implemented
but it's not documented and incomplete
okay you know that's the thing that
connor is talking about
finishing right well actually the thing
is that's the new new packaging
we got to get the terminology right
that's the new new package format
the new package format is in use by a
number of packages for a while now in
layout and that has a set of you know
that does the scan time pass over there
okay
so it's a preliminary version of what
will be the new new package format
yeah is that correct yes
okay um
okay so
the point here is instead of adding to
context
the end package format the function
which right now at
evaluation time adds to dollar context
path
this would prevent that from happening
by essentially blocking dollar context
path or something
this needs context arrow val would
essentially block dollar context path
correct and can see and conceivably
we could also come up with a signature
for n package which would
which would block it you know uh
regardless of how you called needs
yeah and and and we might even choose to
enforce that usage event package
in the packler repository i i we haven't
really discussed that i don't know if
that's good
okay okay fine yeah but then
all right so i mean this looks pretty
reasonable to me
um
you know people do tend to have
you know not that i'm an expert on these
other languages that have import as
but people do seem to have you know a i
mean it must be very very very confusing
to their users but anyway whatever
um you know a sort of standardized oh
you always import this package
as foo or something yeah you know i mean
you know that's that all over the place
i i i can't i can't say how many uh
examples i've
seen of people doing the kind of you
know
numpy hello world type examples that
begin you know
uh import numpy as np
right i understand but the question is
you know np is arbitrary except it's not
right it is arbitrary but a lot of
people happen to use it yeah
no but you see but that's the point
that's how it gets that that's how
things go wrong
right it's because it's like human
language where you know it's
it's like it's arbitrary but everybody
does it this way
nobody ever thought about it and it just
winds up being that that's but it's
but it's explicit right it won't work
unless at the start of your code block
you have import numpy as oh i understand
that although although that becomes
you know it's like um you know
hash includes stand io.h it's like it
becomes a
am or c dot system dd star from a
different period
and and by the way i think that uh you
know in terms of how this works in
notebooks
i mean we already have uh
you know context isolation in notebooks
and you know context isolation basically
gives the front end permission
to fiddle with dollar context path on a
per notebook or even a per
cell group or per cell basis and i think
that
context aliases would be added to that
same isolation mechanism
say that again make me understand so so
this is okay for
the thing that i'm concerned about here
is this idea that
oh the such and such package it's always
called foo
it's always aliased to foo
now so it suggests to me that there
should be a
a proper recommended alias mechanism
um yeah i i i don't
see how i'm skeptical well because
rather than it being an unknown
incantation
right that is just sort of an
incomprehensible incantation because
because then people are going to have
examples that use
oh i don't know i mean what happens in
the example i mean
my plan for the examples is we'll have a
top level
shingle page like we have in all the
repositories where
all the clicked copies give this paclet
symbol wrapper around
it and they'll just work and then within
the actual documentation of the guide
pages and the symbols or not
there won't be any of that it'll assume
that you've done paklet install
and that the yeah and that okay so
listen
the mechanism we need there is when you
copy a cell
out of that piece of documentation it
should somehow
i don't know i it should somehow become
multicellular
and have an initialization piece to it
otherwise we're going to have the
situation that people say oh i've got
all this documentation i'm looking
somewhere in the middle of
you know i i landed there from a web
search i'm in the middle of this page
i copy this thing i copy it and oh
it doesn't work so i'm saying so
the question would be john if you copy a
cell
perhaps from the cloud perhaps from a
notebook whatever that
on paste somehow there could be some
cell options that are set
that causes it to pull in some
initialization or at least
yeah but but but you had i mean that's
that's certainly possible
now but you have to know to set the cell
options
well i know that but we could do that
for documentation we could do that
whenever
for example in any paclet documentation
we could do that
every single cell and patent
documentation would set that
and if we had the right logic if it was
pasted into something where it knows
that that's already been loaded
then it doesn't say anything well and
and so this is a problem
we've already kind of started to have in
in
in certain ways um the uh
well you know i mean anything so we've
used example data to kind of try to work
around some of these cases but sometimes
example data isn't enough
uh you know like i mean when i've tried
to document git link you know it's like
you know i i have to in every single
example start with get opened you know
yeah right i understand i think i think
would be really good to have a mechanism
to have initialization associated with
a copyable cell
i mean i think it would be nice you know
we could imagine a thing where in the
cell bracket there's some indication
that this is a cell
that has some initialization that needed
to run it so
nothing needs to be added to the front
end to do this what
needs to be added to is is the
documentation system to
uh to make it straightforward to
construct uh
examples that that have i didn't know
that okay yeah but i mean i think in the
okay but then so let me understand the
ux of this
so i have this example here and it
requires a bunch of preparation
to make it work right but i just take
this naked cell
i copy it i paste it somewhere what
happens uh
so for what i'm talking about
uh we i mean if you're copying and
pasting
between notebook front ends there's no
problem if if if you're
copying and pasting uh
actually well sorry sorry let me let me
correct that a bit because uh uh i mean
even
in the examples as we have them now
uh the isolation isn't you know
the initialization in isolation isn't
necessarily on a personal basis
it might be a per-cell group basis
because because a particular example
might have a series of inputs
right look my main point is i want to
associate
just initialization code but i don't
want to rerun the initialization code if
i don't need to rerun the initialization
code
sure so do you think that mechanism
exists in the front end right
now to to set up to orchestrate all of
that yes
okay well the uh i mean you know
you know a combination of you know
front-end and kernel features i mean we
have the we have the
once feature uh if all else fails right
yeah that's true yeah good point uh
there are
there are similar things in the front
end if they serve the exact purpose
great but if not we can fall back to
once okay
listen you guys should you guys should
spec this
for for docutools or whatever or for the
modern version of that
this is a really good thing to have this
has been i not realized it was so close
i would personally like to see for a
cell
i mean what about in the original but
but i dodged your question a bit if
if you copy and paste to not a notebook
front end
uh then yeah we would need to make a
front-end change there it wouldn't be
a terrible front-end i think we should
make it we should have a choice then
when you paste it
when you copy oh no no no no no you you
don't get a choice when you paste
no because you get a coach when you copy
yeah
as you know as you know i do not
like dialogue boxes coming up when you
copy
it's uh it's a terrible thing well okay
well in that case
what would it copy by default it would
probably copy the the
the the end result not the preparation
well so we already have a way of
figuring out
what to copy uh you know we have an
option that basically says you know do
you want to preserve evaluation
semantics precisely
do you want to copy rather than the
evaluation symmetrics do you want to
copy something that approximates the
visual appearance well where is that
well i mean that's the copy as mechanism
uh
well that's actually part of
it uses the copy as mechanism but what
i'm referring to
is uh this option called text clipboard
type
um it's a document it's not well that's
not true it's documented
okay great okay but what i might suggest
is that there's some kind of flag in the
cell bracket that indicates this cell is
one that has associated initialization
sorry i was looking up text clipboard
type i didn't catch there's something
i'm saying that
that if it has associated initialization
so indicate
in the cell bracket and possibly also
with the possible original notebook
if you were to just run this i i i mean
you know
you you want to talk about obscure my
thing was at least documented the uh
the cell bracket hieroglyphs i i don't
think
we used to document them but i don't
think they live anywhere in the
documentation anymore no
obviously they have to have a mouse over
that you know
that they didn't have that option in
ancient egypt yeah
the but we we can annotate it
um but but then
just so i understand then if i were to
run that in the source notebook if i
just
go scroll down to that place in the
notebook run this cell
without running the visible
initialization it would
then run the initialization correct
uh modulo some sticky stuff around
you know what i was mentioning in terms
of do you want to isolate
groups instead of individual cells and
then how that interacts with one another
yeah i mean the isolation thing is
difficult this is not solving isolation
this is only solving
if if well yes but uh but the
uh i mean you know what if your goal is
to have an initialization for a group of
three cells
and then you evaluate them out of
sequence you evaluate the third cell by
itself you know should it initialize
there
that's that's the sort of question i'm
asking yeah i would think so
um and and that
yeah that that might require a little
bit of front-end work that might not be
something that we can do right now okay
but it's but it's possible in principle
right so let's go back to the the
original okay so
you guys are not particularly supporting
my recommended alias
concept no is anybody supporting that or
is it dead on rival
i think in the end you know there will
be very few packages
that you know would be popular enough i
i mean yeah okay you know i mean i i
mean you look at
you know repositories that have you know
hundreds of thousands of packages
and you know there are maybe you know in
such a
in you know in a repository like that
there might be five or ten that are
popular
i know i know that's the story of our
efforts to say let's use all these
packages from language x
and it's like well none of them are
actually very useful
yeah um and it's just a
you know a one kilobyte association you
could
publish libraries of aliases
that people could use that could be a
password
okay all right so let's let's walk
through this again
so you're saying that
um actually we have a few comments on
the live stream here
uncle bugsy is is is agreeing with you
john that these dialogues on copy and
paste are a bad idea i
retract i mean of course we do have a
few
you know from external programs
pasting into our notebooks we do have to
have some things and those i think work
really quite yeah but uh fortunately
it's it's uh it's actually quite rare
and
pretty good about knowing if a decision
you know is if if a user decision is
really warranted here yeah no no i know
and
they're useful i mean i i go both ways
on those dialogues so to speak
yeah um okay uh
sandra is asking um
who came up with the word paclet is it
an english word
the answer is uh
long long ago before there were app
stores
we had this idea of doing what is now
essentially the function repository this
is what more than 10 years ago now
well well over 10 years ago oh much more
yeah a long time ago
15 years ago maybe um
yeah right i think it was finally
derailed by resources used for orphan
alpha so i think it must have been
on the order of 15 years ago um in any
case we had the idea
which actually we have not implemented
one part of now
which maybe we should look at again now
the idea was that
we have a mechanism for expanding our
system you know
you start typing a name and the
autocomplete would show you
other related
available functions that you could get
from this what we would now call
repository
and i guess we don't really do that do
we do we do we deal with
unloaded function repository functions
in the autocompletes no uh
uh well sorry i i'm gonna
say i don't know actually oh you're
talking about repository functions i'm
not
i'm not no but i'm what i'm saying is
let's imagine that i start typing
uh you know i start typing just a top
level bird
right we're not giving birds say here
yeah
for for for actual symbols
uh as opposed to you know completion of
strings inside of resource function but
for actual symbols
uh it's only what is actually declared
in the system if it's not in the
department in the system we don't
complete it
right i mean the original idea with what
became called function paclets
was that in this situation you would
also see and it's not totally obvious we
shouldn't do this
and particularly when we have that um
non-contiguous
you know non-prefix autocomplete
what do you call that uh fuzzy fuzzy
completion
okay whatever i mean yeah but where
where this could be bi and it would
still
auto complete to this once we have that
it might actually be not completely
crazy to have
you know names of function repository
things available through this
by the way bi would obviously complete
to that better example would be like bsd
completing the burn bound saunders
distribution
right oh yeah i i didn't see the other
eye yes
yeah um there okay um
okay anyway that's the thing we should
we should revisit that as soon as we
have fuzzy completions
so i think manu is that yes
yeah that that goes to parth sure i can
get out of that
um okay the uh
okay so anyway the question was about
the origin so what happened was
we originally
there was going to be function packages
but then we wanted a
name for a minimal
function package that was just a one
function
thing and it became stephen stephen
stephen
i don't mean to contradict you but i
don't think that's the correct history
of the word packwood
because the word goes back but long
before
the function packet idea came around
that was a
that was a type of packet that
but i'm pretty sure stephen that you and
maybe tom remembers differently but i'm
pretty sure that you actually coined the
word packwood in a meeting
way back at the dawn of this because i
know that there were other names
there was the name as well was the name
we
used i can't remember what we call okay
well the answer is september 2009.
okay i just looked at my archives
september 2004
first use of the name paclet and there's
a
a a discussion of paclets versus
function home pages
so there's there's some
let's see hold on one second here the
discussion might still be relevant
it might still be relevant yes
right but i guess i always understood
this right just a small
package just like an apple yes
that's exactly okay so the answer is
september 2004 so we can we can
define that and there's i'm not
seeing evidence here and it is
definitely not an english word
yeah uh i mean exceptionally right
um
um
yeah i'm i'm i can't validate
by september 3rd 2004 i was sending mail
saying paclets versus function home
pages
and um uh looks like um biggest activity
wow for the name pack that was actually
between 2009 2011
at least for me um that was probably the
that was i'm guessing the function
packet
repository uh stage where we were
working on that and discussing that
um i have to bring this up just for
just for fun this is from peter obermann
and this i assume i don't know what this
is actually going to be so this might be
totally scary but
but um this seems to be
oh there's a dialogue on paste
oh this was a
sample paclet from peter obermann
um dated
january 10 2005.
15 years okay so that's the answer
um
uh
yes no it's a made-up word and um and it
wasn't a typo
and um uh yes it was a uh
a minimized um um
yeah it was intended to be a minimal
package but that wasn't contradicting
what i said was it todd
no it's just that the idea
it was really data package it was one of
the very first
motivations for the packard system and
that's right
that was later that was significantly
later that was after the
paclet concept had been established in
the function case
and we had gotten pretty close we had
mock-up the whole function mechanism
i think data packets didn't didn't
happen until 2007.
two years later really okay yeah because
they were they were in the run-up
to to or from alpha they were the first
feature of
alfa that was released right we even
before anybody knew about wolfman alpha
so to speak
um
the uh
right somebody's noting that um uh
it's nice that we remember these things
yeah well 2004
is that that's you sent some mail about
in 2004
yes that's what i just found yes
what's that spelling dictionaries
are you serious that's what spelling it
that the word
email the subject was spelling
dictionaries i forward it to you
sure but but but i mean i would have it
if i sent it
um you mean it was it was about paclets
in the spelling dictionary
this is the yes wrestling it's the
package i can find
in my system which is probably inferior
to yours but
for what it's worth sorry
well please send it if you wish
each folder under there
i see this was a uh
oh yeah yeah you know what you know what
we had
a an internal male alias
for paclets starting in by 2005 there
was an internal melee house discussing
these
yeah i just looked at the first commit
into the packard manager
or in 16 years ago 15
years ago seven months so that would
have been 2004.
sandra is apologizing for derailing our
meeting with with
uh yeah discussing um but it is
interesting
credit for the name stephen i do think
you coined that word yeah i'm probably
sure i i agree with that right
there um
i'm just looking at this piece of mail
from from you tom
that i think is still relevant i'm gonna
bring it up
from 2005. um
that's not relevant presumably
i don't know that i've even ever heard
of this kobas person
what do you mean come on
i think it's a good idea that you
haven't actually no
you two might not get on perfectly but
but
you both have interesting how is your
diplomatic side in time
okay um okay
in any case all right let's let's uh
let's
let's come back to this all right
um there was another
comment here from ethan
first time you want to run a symbol from
the paclet repository it would be nice
to interactively be prompted for one
click installation
yeah i think that makes sense uh
we i'm not sure if that's part of our
running proposal but
i i agree that there's a certain amount
of sense there
right i'd like to talk about one thing
with respect to that
when i see actually two points here um
in the function repository when there is
an update to a function repository
um function i get this stupid message
where i have to then copy out something
from the message i mean
in other words let's say i try and use
something for which there is an update
what i would really like is that there's
a piece of ux
that interactively prompts me to update
the thing
i mean i would be perfectly happy if it
threw that thing
into some i mean right now it's coming
out in notebook
as a essentially a warning message right
right possibly it should throw it to a
notifier of some kind maybe through the
channel framework or something
that is a global notification of their
maybe that's a stupid idea
but but you get what i'm saying but
right now it comes out as a piece of
text which is really annoying
and you have to the only thing i know to
do is to copy from the warning message
into a new cell and run the uh the
packet update
right we used to have a button but the
ux was bad because people thought it was
updating like
in time right in that evaluation
which didn't make any sense right
because you would only see i see the
elevation already let's walk through
this for one second right
okay did do other people here understand
the issue so is so the problem is you
have like a typeset resource function
which is
referring to a specific uuid that's that
is locked on a version is that the no
the ui is not locked on a version now
let me let me show an example i mean i
wonder whether i don't know if bird say
has been updated
but let's just see no give me something
that's been updated recently
well you could do it the data repository
covered things get updated
every day about uh okay all right okay
that'd be resource object
um okay you could also ask her the old
version of bird say
no that won't do it for me i need a
thing
um should just be able to resource
object open and start typing epidemic
and it should
auto complete to the covid thing that
gets updated all the time
resource data resource object i would do
otherwise we'll sit here for
three minutes watching you download
epidemic
okay oh well that's ours it should have
the one for a covet
in the autocomplete one would have
thought one would have thought
it's not called something else like
pandemic or something is it
no that's not no no it's called epidemic
epidemic data from your that's just so
depressing
could you get that fixed please that the
auto complete list
you know there's been a pandemic going
on for uh
close to a year and we don't have that i
mean we have all the data being updated
every time i
sorry i thought there was a process this
was supposed to be up yeah on a monthly
basis
no even more than that um i don't
i'll i'll figure out why that one's not
in there
um i just put it in
i must not have had the i must not have
already had this in this um
uh okay so let me explain what would
have happened
so you you basically you have a locally
cached version that's older
than what's on the server that's correct
exactly
and then what happens is when i to ask
for the resource
object here it will come up with a
message
right that says this is not the most
recent version
blah blah blah blah blah but then it
will go ahead and return
that right version it'll complete the
evaluation with the cached version
well you know the correct ux here would
be to make
this box have something which is like
that i'm not loaded in the notebook load
me now thing
yeah i mean that makes sense when you're
returning the resource object but if
it's
resource data or if it's wrapped in
another evaluation right that's not
that's not useful right and it also
doesn't update percent which
could lead to other types of confusion
we we do have if you have an
out of date uh resource object
there is an update button under the fold
in the blog
for the function free source function
okay listen if that's the case
right it shouldn't be below the fold if
it if it requires an update
it should not be below the fold
requires is a strong word well no no if
there is an update
it should not be below the fold yeah
sure we can do that
okay that's an easy fix but that's not
solving the problem of it being inside
code
could we make the button
bubble up to the input cell and
re-evaluate the input cell after
updating the data
well so the issue is at runtime so you
know a given piece of code might have
three
out of date packets in it three out of
date resources in it
okay each one generates a message says
you can update this you can update this
let's say they have buttons those
buttons if they are pressed will not
affect the current evaluation they will
only affect subsequent evaluations
i i mean i don't like the idea of
preempting at all
what am i pretty i'm saying well i don't
want to like stop the evaluation and
wait for the user to make a decision
no absolutely not right
so maybe it's a messaging problem i mean
look there's two possibilities
that i can see one there might be a way
of messaging it in that
message two it might be worthwhile to
have some global
you know there are updates ready for you
now oh yeah okay
yeah and we have a way to update
everything you have cached
with resource update open close i think
or resource update all
well so maybe that should be in the
toolbar right and then
there's also the resource version option
as of
12 1 where you can do research version
goes to no but i'm latest or here's the
ux that i'm suggesting
okay the message comes out here
says there's a new version and then
it has a button that takes you
somehow to a control panel for updating
these these functions yeah what's that
yeah that makes sense yeah then there's
no idea you know that then
that's a separate control panel nobody
thinks it's going to update the
particular
thing you already have right the control
panel is making the control panel
is a lot of gui and design work but yes
well that's a good idea i'm not sure how
much of a control panel it really needs
to be
i mean it could be as simple but the
question again
it reminds me a bit of uh
something like the messages window or
something like when you're
saving notebooks to the cloud and that
spins off into a background process with
that
uh window that shows you the progress of
its uploading
exactly yeah i think that's the right
way to do it and and that could be hung
off the what could happen is if if it
finds that there is a package that needs
to be updated
there could be a little red thing that
comes up in the toolbar when we have a
standardized toolbar that says you know
updates are waiting for you just like it
does in web browsers and other things
yeah sort of a resource administration
toolbar palette sort of thing
it's definitely a good idea it's been on
the radar for a while and we haven't
really
all right but but i think nick could be
generalized beyond resource objects as
well
to what well to paclets in particular
yeah well okay but but look i think it's
the right way to do it and i think we
should
try and get a minimal design for this
and this will solve the problem
of this stupid you know this solves the
ux confusion of this
message make sense
yes okay good
uh
are we back to aliases yet
um i think we are yes hold on one second
um
um yes was there something else i was
going to say about the um
uh
no okay right great i mean to me this
you know i think is there any more to
say about it well it's
i mean you know feel free to walk
through the examples i tried to cover
i think most of the interesting things
and examples with
these are not live examples these are
mocked outputs but
to give you an idea of what to expect
i see so that is the equivalent of what
i was saying might be colon colon equals
or something is this thing here
yes yep
that's a little bit of a weird left hand
side we don't have a lot of dolla blah
i i'm not opposed to something like the
colon colon
equal in principle i i just didn't think
of it but
uh maybe
i don't know i don't think it needs to
necessarily be that short
but i'm wondering whether this you know
like like when when you tell people out
of three you know look at every output
prompt it says out of three equals
right you know when you tell people that
means that out of three is equal to that
they get very sort of cognitively
confused often
they didn't think of it as it actually
meant what it said
yeah and you know that makes me feel
that this would be better off with a
function
that's called set you know set alias or
something
that does this even though you might be
able to do this raw
thing if you wanted to well see but
this is kind of a fake isn't it because
this is
this would have to be faked because it's
not the case that a pure association
there
would do this yes it is yes it is
there's nothing fake about it the only
thing that's fake about it is
uh what you see in the scope where it it
you know it really
you know it has behaviors if you try to
violate its association-ness
am i just monumentally confusedly
confused
okay good the okay so if i say
this you know a goes to one
okay now i say ffb
equals four
there you go
it's just like smp they used to do that
too
i was so allergic to that for 25 years
that's it that's
in my view that's one of the brilliant
and useful things about associations we
use that in the front end all the time
i should use that a lot more i think i
was i mean that was
that was the great unification of snp
the problem was it went too far
and it tried to make vectors you know
lists
be this but with the indices just being
one two three four
and by the way equal dot also does what
you think it should
you know ffb equal dot removes that
well that's nice but you see the thing
okay so
let me show you the the the let me show
you the thing
that made me allergic to this for 25
years or more
smp would take that object there
okay and it would make that equivalent
to
the list abc
it's like javascript
really they do that yeah oh how
fascinating
well there are no new ideas under the
sun the
i guess um
anyway that was a disaster i guess it
hasn't worked out
well i don't know what it's done for
javascript but in other words what would
happen is
as soon as you filled in the whole thing
it would suddenly turn into that
uh you know dense list so if you had one
and three
it would just be an association-like
thing they were called um
boy what were they called they were
called functions are called projections
but what the heck were those things
called
i only remember somebody having the joke
of calling them optical benches
because functions were called
projections and arguments were called
filters
um maybe we never named those things
anyway
doesn't matter um
let's see but but yeah the disaster was
that that it was just so bizarre to know
and that must
you know what i've heard people complain
about that in javascript too that it's
bizarre to know when it turns into a
list and when it's an association
i think in effect it doesn't turn into
anything else that's what it is
i see but there's the issue abstract
thing on that's the abstract model
there's some probably deeper thing
jitted the point is that for example
there are plenty of things that you
might do
on the list that you couldn't expect to
do on an association
yeah there's really weird subtleties to
iterating over lists and javascript that
i think come down to this
like there's two different operators you
use i forget what they are
but it always bit me when i wrote
javascript
i think these are subtleties that you
know boy if there was more of a
discipline of language design people
would know these things
somebody would have actually known that
this was something that was tried in snp
and what went wrong as opposed to it
being rediscovered
okay in any case um xkd
about this lisp cycles
oh right these are your father's
parentheses
yeah right well did you know okay here's
a piece of
of language trivia for you did you know
and i just learned this
you know as i was doing this research
about combinators that in john
mccarthy's original paper about lisp
he had two formats that he proposed for
lisp
the s expression format with parentheses
and the m expression format
have you seen this have you seen the m
expression format
i i've heard of it but i don't remember
it's basically well from language
expressions right it is yes
it is it's got square brackets square
brackets um yeah
um everything i'm just trying to see if
i can
um uh let's see whether i can find this
just for a second because it's really
amusing i
mean i literally just found this um
oh let me see if i can just pull it up
for one second and then then we will get
back to the um
you know what i i signed up to do a um
um
a live stream about uh q a about history
of science and technology which actually
isn't about an hour and a bit
so maybe i'm segueing into that but let
me just find this just because it really
was
quite amusing um
oh here we go
here we go this is this is john
mccarthy's paper and look at that
look at those square brackets the only
the the difference and and the plan
and i remember actually talking to john
mccarthy about this that he was like
well
you know we were going to do the s
expressions first and then we're going
to do the m
expressions uh but that was in 1959 and
we never got around to the m expressions
um but but uh the difference is that
their
argument delimiter was semicolon not
comma
well well it said they got the comma
they just
added the bit more they just yeah yeah
right added that extra bit of ink there
you put a thought over the comma right
anyway
okay so um right ethan is suggesting
um backtick
equal is what he's suggesting that was
mangled in the copy paste but backtick
equal yeah
right
but that's that's ambiguous isn't it
maybe it isn't ambiguous
um yeah yeah you can't end a
symbol name with backtick right
you can only end us something that is a
context and string but that's
interesting because that would be
that would be a very literal thing
you're saying this context
well except what it's looking like is
that context is being aliased
to this
it's not the worst thing in the world
because it is effectively a context
you can end a number
like you can't set a number on the
left-hand side of an equals yeah
i mean the weird thing is you know it's
it's kind of like
the the the name
and the backtick equal they all have to
sort of scan as one thing i think
right or right or we need to figure out
some way to auto stringify right because
string
context is literally that thing there
i would be very dubious of this syntax
well okay i think it's an interesting
idea
and i think uh you know it's a part it
makes more sense than colon colon equals
i mean are there also going to be
symbols set
set context alias clear context daily
sort of thing
i think we should have that i think this
is what's that
i would that i would want that
especially like if i'm writing it in a
package file not a notebook okay it's
not obvious to me that the term context
alias i mean i
i do like this notion of import as
and well and and and that's of course
you're
right there at the bottom you're seeing
the needs example which we've already
discussed
um
um by the way i'm just i'm i'm i'm being
told i should plug the science and
technology q a
at uh um the top of the
the hour after this coming one at five
o'clock eastern time
um maybe maybe as one of the topics we
can talk about the history of um uh
uh lisp and so on just um just fyi
stephen since we've gone 20 minutes over
and probably another 10 minutes or so
some repair people are coming and i will
have to disappear
so okay but don't don't okay you you
will
yeah right okay the are they repairing
you or someone never mind
not not me but you know i i think right
no
no no no i don't want them to break down
the door you see yeah right
um okay in any case
um so
the question is are people actually
going to be typing this or is this a low
level thing
like monkeying with context path which
you don't typically do
well yeah i think that's a good question
um i mean
certainly you know my initial thought
is that the needs syntax
is you know probably
them going to be the most popular way of
doing this or i would think so
yeah i mean this low-level thing yeah we
can support it
and then maybe it's fine as you have it
so okay so what else do you want to show
here okay so well so
along with needs there's begin package
which just basically follows needs
um right and any changes
that you make either as a result of
begin package
or inside of begin package or then
reverted by end package
you know i'm just so bothered by the
fact that you have this code i mean
one of the things that's really really
nice about our language in general
is that because sort of batteries are
included with everything you can copy a
piece of code
and it'll basically just run as soon as
we're doing this
where the actual
i mean i suppose you could say anytime
i've defined a function f that's not
true
but yeah maybe this is the same thing
i'm just it bothers me that you will
have big lumps of code that say ep
backtick whatever and taken out of their
natural habitat they will not run
i mean that's true for package
development all the time
fair enough fair enough it really is
yeah okay for any non-trivial pack maybe
for a trivial package
might not be true but for any
non-trivial package it's definitely true
okay but the thing about using needs for
this
and i recognize that's that's a
convenient syntax
needs is sort of like the setting the
context series but needs also has the
side effect of trying to load
a context i might want to use context
aliases for
packages for context that are not on
that are not packages right a private
context or
or something right i might well want to
make a context alias or something that
i wouldn't want needs to attempt to load
i understand like a private alias that
you're for debugging for example
yeah well an alias to a context that
doesn't map to a package and therefore
can't
be loaded with needs right something
maybe maybe a
a private context within my package i
just want to
make an alias for that so i would have
to use there are some uses but you have
to use
whatever low-level function we provide
for explicitly setting an alias
and the question is the bottom-most
example
is is a version of that sorry
it was the bottom most you just scrolled
it um
which one but it where uh uh
next one down uh by the way
it says and package restores dollar
context aliases regardless of how
auditions were made so
in this case an addition was made inside
the package
okay i get it what about this case here
where you're saying there's certain
things that cannot be set up as aliases
right so this and dollar context path
does something similar you can't just
you know assign dollar context path to
any old expression you know it's got to
be a list of you know
a list of contacts and that's uh
so this is a different thing this is a
this is essentially a sock puppet
context or something
that you're oh wait so and by the way i
i put the xxx there because that's kind
of an open question you know
should it the other three i think are
you know i stand behind this one i don't
know
um maybe maybe not maybe it's an issue
maybe not
yeah legal symbol name is fine right
otherwise
otherwise we're gonna you know good it's
not very useful if it doesn't deliver
yeah the question here is should you be
able to
i mean i can see all kinds of sort of
nasty security like things you know
it's like a yes like a phishing thing
you know you think you're typing into
this password dialogue
but actually it's another password yes
yes exactly
seems like a bad idea to allow you to to
alias
i mean i don't understand why you would
ever want to alias something for which
that context already exists
why would you ever want to alias
something that's on the context path
well there might be some times when you
when you don't realize that context
exists like
like the whack-a-mole problem
well yes but i mean it's fine to tell
you because what's going to happen
i don't understand how this could
possibly work in other words
insofar as you can call something yeah
no it
creates an ambiguity and right and we
have to make sure
i think i think what we should do is
just say you can't
set a context alias for a context that
exists
and now here's two questions that exists
on the context path that's a pretty
clear answer
that exists anywhere in the system is a
less clear answer well now both of those
questions
raise the obvious okay what happens if
you
uh add the alias then create the context
well look this is a big pile of gunk
right yeah we clearly know what all of
these are but it's a big pile of gunk
um
although maybe uh maybe creating the
context you know
creating the context after you have the
uh alias
it gets difficult but not necessarily
impossible
because your point is as soon as you
type it in it's it's just running the
alias
yes exactly well how would you create it
without i mean you could
could you do it well so there are uh
there are some corner cases if you
scroll farther down
uh you know things like what are we
doing with uh
uh names uh uh
and uh
yeah what are we doing with names what
are we doing with context
uh i have some open questions around
stuff like this okay but so so
i have a question here so this
the question is how can you create a
symbol
in a certain context
without referring to that context
i mean clearly you might be able to do
it by saying to expression
of some constructed string but even that
now and notice my first properties and
relations
shows that to expression uses aliases
okay in this by the way recently i was
thinking two expression needs a context
path
option which it doesn't have right now
in fact i would claim several functions
like cloud evaluate
to expression they need a context path
don't they
or am i confused you could you can wrap
them in a block
they use the current context path right
so if you block the context back
i know but it would be it would be nice
to have the possibility
to have them you know to have a two
expression which is a safe to expression
that doesn't use you know that doesn't
have
i don't know this came up recently in
some very confused situation
using two expression inside some package
or something
that had some weird context path
i mean it's part of setting the
environment which
okay for cloud evaluate and the future
local evaluate
or session evaluate for example um
how do you set the environment
here's another question by the way not
just context path but
context as well presumably
what do you mean contexts well i i mean
where are you going to
where do new symbols get created they
get created in dollar context that
doesn't have anything to do with
context path that's true i'd go a step
further and say
the contents of the symbol table i mean
what symbols are considered to exist
already or not
well yes i mean that's a more sandbox
more serious sandbox
you know what it could have been that my
problem was a two expression
in fact i think we've had this problem i
think this problem exists in various
cloud cases and it exists in the
function repository
the two expression is operating in the
context in which it finds itself
and sometimes that's a privatized
context so it creates a symbol in some
totally wacky context
yeah you know i think we our earlier
versions of manipulate had
issues like this where symbols would
kind of pop out with uh
particularly in um uh
in documentation examples would pop out
with weird contexts
bob is sending with a link to the this
um
uh context module by rich which is
somewhat
related where you can evaluate an
expression
in a dedicated context i think you can
also imagine where you specify
this is a good lcc discussion about
localizing
contexts and local into expression and
so on
but but back to this it seems to me we
do not know but somebody should
determine it
whether there is a way to create a
context without
you know create a symbol in a context
without naming the context
if there isn't the course is clear we
just say
you can't make an alias where the
left-hand side is an exist
is a is an existing context and you will
never be able to
you know create a context with an alien
with a name that is the left-hand side
of an alias
because you always have to refer to that
name and then you've
you know then then you're going to be
sent back to the
alias right hand side
right if i'm not confused there
john do you agree ah sorry it's uh
i got uh pinged through chat and i and i
lost a bit of that sentence
okay all right so so okay we should wrap
up in a moment here but but um
the i mean sorry about that the point
the point i was making is
do you believe it is possible to create
a
a context without naming the context
in such a way that the context name will
be translated by the aliases
so i i i kind of
don't think so but i i'm not the one who
knows kind of
all of the dark corners okay well fine
so that's a
that's an lcc question you should try to
try to resolve that
yeah um okay
yeah you know like like for example the
the new new package format
you know do we like the term context
alias
or do we think it's i think it's
probably okay for this level of stuff
and possibly set context alias might
have a syntax
if it becomes commonly enough used sure
yeah but otherwise it's just going to be
part of the needs thing
now in terms of names
why wouldn't this just be operating
through the alias mechanism just like
every other
place where you name a symbol i mean so
that abc backtick would expand
oh i see what you're saying i see what
you're saying you want to make a query
does the thing exist and you want to
make that query ignoring
the aliasing that that is does it raw
exist does it
that there's two levels of existence
here yes it exists
as a as a genuine
output of the scanner and there's
exists as something you can type in and
names
already has some fuzzy behavior i mean
names takes the ignore case option for
example
so it kind of makes sense that name
should have something like ignore alias
at least to me
yeah well i mean i think it would be
ignore context aliases or something uh
that's fine um
is there anything else like names i mean
names
contexts which is immediately below it
uh although context doesn't take any
options context is
is so far well no i'm sorry context does
take patterns though
um yeah it would be fine to have the
same ignore context aliases would be a
fine thing i think there
and otherwise it's just going to tell
you context of abc would tell you
yeah if it was a pattern so it could be
a pattern that would match to aliases
rather than to context themselves or by
saying ignore context aliases
you would be requiring a match to the
pure patterns
yes but the case you're not covering
there
is a match to context aliases but not
to uh you know correct but but in that
case you can always just
inspect dollar context aliases yeah i
know but it's a piece of code to do that
but it's fine i don't think that's a big
issue
information is probably similar to names
it is
yes that would have to be covered does
it tell you it's an alias or does it
tell you the information about
the alias
uh yeah you know i i was just thinking
of information in terms of you know
looking at symbols i wasn't thinking of
kind of
i think does information take context
names yeah it takes
context yeah oh
no that's the full symbol the symbol
fully qualified symbol as this
what about why doesn't it and it
probably should take a context name
wow funky that should work we should
make that work that will be useful
just like you know just like the summary
of
of um i mean just like if i do this
that would work you see
that's what information of that should
do somehow
that makes sense okay so information
does not
take an option at it as best as i can
tell
okay but fine but but what i'm saying is
okay first point and this is for the
people
and that's another story if he wasn't
off being repaired or whatever
um the uh you know
that this information of a context
should do something interesting uh i'm
gonna be meeting with eta in about an
hour
i'll i'll relay that to him okay
um okay so i mean because this
you know if i say this
it does what it does right by the way i
really hate this and this is something
again this is probably from manu this
thing that says symbol
in big letters just it's just wrong that
it's so big
just that should be much smaller and
okay in any case but but my point is if
it is an alias
what it should do a little bit like in a
file system you know it will show you a
symbolic link
and then it shows you well i'm not sure
it's
completely like that but but the idea is
i think if it's an alias thing
it should show you the alias and then it
should show you the expansion of the
alias
in information okay
and if you ask about since we're not
even making this work yet at all
information of that i mean
okay so a question is if you say
question mark okay here's here's a case
question mark a star b backtick foo
okay so the question is does that
pattern patternize
both the alias and
the raw context oh that's an excellent
question that i did not address
okay
um
i think it should probably patternize
both of them i think it has no choice i
don't see it what else it could possibly
mean
two string should not change it right
change what if you give the the alias it
should
just turn that into a string it
shouldn't give the the underlying
symbol as a string uh
no it's everything i mean this is being
a scan time thing like
if you look at the there's an example of
uh
where is it at john the question is does
the does the context itself does the
aliased context itself
expand or does it only expand when it is
you know hydrated with a symbol name
do you see what i'm saying so these are
two different cases this case
and this case here wait well actually
i'm typing nonsense here yeah thank you
oh okay
so in fact this doesn't make any sense
anyway because that's not legal syntax
and and in terms of the second example
the second example is informed by
uh is this my second example under
properties and relations
so this is not evaluation time it's a
scan time
right so yes okay so right that thing it
never hits
the the evaluator with that
exactly okay
um in other words context of that thing
is always going to return the aliased
context
yes return the
yeah it will resolve all aliases yes
okay is there a way to discover aliases
for a symbol
to go the other way uh
well i mean dollar context aliases
will i guess yeah yeah yeah you could
build it easily
yeah all right i consider this design a
success
i think i think we're good here okay
and uh great all right just a reminder
for people it's the first of our
uh perhaps series of science and
technology q as
at the top of the next style so anybody
who's interested
is encouraged to join and to come up
with the
questions about history of science and
technology
all right that's it for for this year
thanks a lot to everybody
thank you